first we want to start with Star Wars
Battlefront oddly enough we haven't
really done much on it since like it
released last year around that time at
least and you've kind of been you and
Aaron maybe have been one of the two of
the people who are in the office Rob
that kind of been coming back to the dlc
yeah each time around just kind of
touching on what's new what's changed
this time around it's I go back and
forth with battlefront we've all played
it I'm sure like you know as a Star Wars
fan like you have these all moments and
you appreciate the visuals and the sound
effects and all that stuff and you know
it's all done really well but then you
just start getting frustrated along the
way and that's where I'm kind of at with
this DLC but it's been pretty cool I
think it's a it's a neat little package
so far so just give you more of those
sort of like all moments or like the
nostalgia stuff I mean is that kind of
what this game that sounds like that's
pretty much all I can rely upon
I haven't played any the DLC but I
imagine like getting more of that is
probably yeah and that's worth yeah and
that's it's exactly that and that's
where the the run I go with this stuff
it kind of ends where it's like I feel
like I've seen all the spectacle of it
and then it kind of just dries out
because the gameplay is just not that
great I mean the other I'm sure there's
a fanbase who appreciate it and clearly
because there are a lot of people ready
to go that game and but yeah this time
around it's Death Star so there's like
three game modes or maps so to speak and
they all kind of transition into each
other mm-hm the first being a the rebels
attack a Star Destroyer outside of the
Death Star and then the next is on the
Death Star the rebels attack I'm trying
to get to it like it's like a um what's
the game mode
it's basically a like a moving spawn
point where the rebels are trying to get
r2d2 off the Death Star and onto this
rebel transport and he has he has the
Death Star plans so like the movie and
then the next is just the Death Star
trench run and I feel mixed on each one
of those they also added new heroes
there's always two in each one for each
side and burial rebel this one is boss
the Bounty Hunter mm-hmm wait to know
what alien race he is I was forgetting
forget
I don't know he's not like cuz grito is
what a Rhodesian oh sorry radians like
yeah and then the other one being
Chewbacca himself which I haven't been
able to play yet but they have some
pretty you know they always have
interesting kind of perks and abilities
Chewbacca has one where I guess where he
just goes his typical Chewbacca roar and
then surrounding allies near you get
beefed up fantastic rookies the audio
yeah I'm terrible with those something
get to try to do it it looks like Bosque
has some sort of thermal vision I think
right try to do it no that I'm never
gonna top not bad up that's more what
Tuscan Raider but okay so these I mean
it's the Death Star interior right so I
would assume unless there are big
hangers you come into it's kind of a
claustrophobic confined like close
quarters that's what I that's why I
don't really like the that stage just
because it's so hard like you just
constantly dying or at least I am and I
think everyone is I mean it's tough yeah
it's really close quarters it makes you
realize that that Death Star with all
those steep no railing like drops how
funny they are with P no jet packs or
some of the like it's like the hot item
in that game so people were jumping up
and then hitting the ceiling and falling
breaking their neck right it's tough in
in these corridors but you know it's
again the spectacle value is really cool
so you'll see like what I imagined to be
a rendition of the control room with the
desks are has you know all those scenes
another one is I think it starts off
with r2d2 near the prison area where
Leia is however you walk down that
famous hallway and it just goes it's not
connected to anything it just actually
literally just goes off boundaries yeah
when I first saw I saw about eight guys
running down there and then all turning
back because there's nothing you know
there's nothing to go towards that gap
where Luke does the grappling hook
across it and then Leia like hugs him so
tight that she's like inside his chest I
didn't see that no you don't see that
you see some hangers and you see
definitely the same area where obi-wan
turns down the shield's no spoiler
I want to ask you guys a question
collectively like so seeing all this
stuff is great and this is like the
first time we've seen sorta like the
classic Star Wars movies represented in
whatever next-gen right like these
consoles they can only whip this stuff
out once in a while before it starts to
feel like yeah we've seen this recently
do you guys think that the fact that
they've kind of executed on this in such
a middling average way means that well
maybe this is the best we're gonna get
this generation that kind of sucks
because he'll imagine like a really good
recreation of this stuff this gen
they're not gonna try to do it again
immediately following this does it feel
like a missed opportunity because I kind
of feel that way which Star Wars
specifically yes game yeah tackling the
classic movies like showing these scenes
that we all know and love and doing in a
way that is just not quite delivering
that like wow you know like it's all
caveated by the things that make this
game kind of sure I mean like I reviewed
this bet last year and that was my thing
it was like the spectacle is there for
sure and it's there especially if you're
a star Wars fan you're kind of screaming
over Hoth and a snow speeder but there
wasn't much substance to the combat in
order like in terms of like making use
of the Star Wars license and whatnot I
don't think we've seen anything
spectacular recently at all I mean like
the older public people gush about but I
mean that's like you know that's not
like the classic Star Wars movies um I
don't know like the studio is working on
stuff right now there's you have people
at EA that are working on it like Amy
Hennig studio is working on one kind of
wondering what that's gonna be like but
battlefront has always been milling to
me at best I haven't been playing the
DLC I think that was the overarching
question I want to ask you is any of it
worth coming back for is earth and is it
like I'm lending more vitality to the
game yeah like so that interior Death
Star stuff with the actual infantry
combat again yeah it's it's just it's
just a [ __ ] like I don't even
know where I'm going for the most part
like yeah I see a r2d2 icon rolling
around yet where enemies are attacking
you from you'd never get like the
spawning is a little poor where I never
gauge what is the layout of this map but
then yeah touching on like the Death
Star mode I'm sorry the trench run mode
that was actually pretty cool
despite the controls of these of these
ships are awful in my opinion like just
awful I am so frustrated with how they
handled it and that you can't do you
know actual 101 barrel rolls like you
you do oh yeah it's really dumb it's
it's like a you know a pan so look I can
do a flip and the next thing I know I'm
upside down and I then it's weird and
then the control switch it's like okay
well you got a straight now bud
so like you're you're turning then
equates to like spinning back around but
it ends up making you crash
however this truth the trench run was
really interesting in that you the
rebels basically have to hit checkpoints
in order to have the ultimate goal of
doing the classic Luke Skywalker
shooting photon torpedoes down the
exhaust but what was neat is they and
this is where my worry was was that okay
let's get real the trench run it's kind
of a boring layout right it's just a
trench run what obstacles are there
others enemy lines other than like a
slight box feel boring starfox 64 right
level but what they did is they actually
included very reminiscent of the second
Death Star internet Jedi some actual
tunnels and one area in the tunnel is
straight up the exact representation of
returning tide gets our to where the
Malema Falcon loses its radar dish yeah
what's going through so I'm a TIE
Interceptor and I'm chasing the Luke so
it every random every so often you are
picked to be as a rebel Luke Skywalker
you have to basically be the x-wing and
everyone the map shows you anyways you
get these really intense chases where
you going through these tunnels just
like an eternity guy Jedi and it's like
next week goes in and it's like eight
Taif iiters swarming in behind them and
just crashing because it's really tough
to like get this chase down and you know
a lot of obstacles in the way that was
pretty neat
I think they touching back what you said
Peter I think they have been able to tap
into that spectacle in an appropriate
manner like seeing that exact
representation it is it looks really
great of that one moment in the de
second Death Star was really neat and I
felt like I was really doing you know
you want to be in that movie right and I
had that for a few seconds but then the
controls just go go whack and I can't I
can't have fun where that's the barrier
is like the flying is so poor that I
just can't enjoy it yeah it just feels
those moments are stymied by just the
kind of okay game beneath it right when
these things kind of deserve something
better like more attention paid to the
specific moment at hand like to get that
much more focus on it beyond just
putting you there beyond just giving you
a means to interact with it like really
figure out okay what made this special
let's tailor everything to make that
feel special for someone playing it
versus cramming into another game it
always felt very much like an ode to
Star Wars rather than I'd like a good
Star Wars game in itself yeah so it's
like it's like a toy box for Star Wars
fans almost and like that's why I
appreciate it and that's why I think
it's it's decent but I just every time I
get in I play a match and then I'm just
bored I mean I say like in the present
tense but I hadn't played in eight
months or so sure but I I was curious
whether this DLC was anything that like
it was building on the games foundation
or whether was just giving you more of
what I thought was a middling game to
begin with mm-hmm anyway
cool so that is Star Wars Battlefront
the newest DLC is the Death Star there's
one coming out early next year
rogue one is Gareth do you know anything
about that a little bit yeah that sounds
pretty intriguing and perfectly lines up
with rogue one so I'm not sure what
planet's caref is but I do know is that
the heroes for that are Ben middle syns
character the director Orson critic
cranek Orson Clinic and then and then
you play Jenner so on the rebel side so
that could be really neat I mean you
know having a movie come out with that'd
be cool to see what they do there but
again hopefully it's good hopefully who
knows cool well you will be streaming
that right after the lobby today won't
you that is right awesome
so that is start with battlefronts
newest dlc the death star dlc it's out
now on ps4 Xbox one and PC if you have
the season pass if you do not have the
season pass you have to wait two weeks
and then you can start getting in there
okay cool let us know if you're gonna
pick it up in the comments below